also breaking here at this noon hour
ccsd police have arrested a cashman
middle school student for allegedly
making a threat against the campus this
morning we told you about a viral post
over social media that was encouraging
violent threats against schools
nationwide
up north in fact in carson city the
district decided to play it safe and
close all schools today classes however
went on as planned at ccsd hector mejia
joining us now live near decatur and
desert in hector what else do we know
about the rest of this student
well ccsd police say the threat was made
online by a juvenile although a gun was
not found on campus still we saw a
number of parents show up here pulling
their student from class as soon as they
got a phone call from the principal
about this
clark county school police watched over
cashman middle after a student made a
threat here friday morning charges can
include making a terrorist threat among
others ccsd reminding everyone about the
severe consequences students can face
i'm always worried about
you know it happening at
schools my kids go to the day had
already started with some anxiety the
district previously sent an email saying
it was aware of vague social media
threats directed at schools nationwide
cecilia freeman has two grandchildren at
ccsd i'm not even sure if i'm like
dropping her off yeah good grandma i got
my party today
it's the last day of school before
winter break and finals week over at
rancho high school where we met jared
dean as he dropped off his son at school
with columbine ever since then
it's been happening more frequently
where
it almost we almost become numb to the
violence in school so i think we always
need to take it very seriously
the student involved in this specific
incident here has not been identified
because they are a minor this is also a
reminder for students to go ahead and
use the safe voice app to report
anything that looks suspicious or any
threat or to go ahead and report it
directly to law enforcement reporting
outside cashman middle school hector
mejia live local now